Ви мене вибачте але я от не знаю за що
мені дякувати пану міністру може за
закриті незалежні телевізійні канали
може зателемарафон який промиває містке
населення в принципі я можу і подякував
Хоча я розумію що це не він він гвинтик
в цій системі де він слухняно виконує
вказівки по фактично знищенню культурної
сфери так пан міністр каже що культура
це кіно але
розуміння моє про культуру це Сенцов
який воює на фронті а розуміння п
міністра це серіал про паровоза тому на
цю культуру в нас абсолютно різне
бачення ви знаєте мама моя працює в
школі в бібліотеці і зараз займається
тим що списує російські книжки і
бібліотека перекладені вже видані
російською мовою і бібліотека стане
порожньою тому що український книжок там
немає бо гроші на це ніхто не збирає
виділяти я приходжу в цей зал і кожен
день дивлюся порядок денний і дивлюся
коли ж там з'являться смартфони про
заборону діяльності російської В церкви
в Україні але вони там не з'являються
записали на завтра в кінці щоб не
проголосувати Так це велика досягнення
що ми помилилися за Мазепу святій
українській Лаврі вперше за 30 років але
хіба може зараз під час повномасштабного
вторгнення це п'ята колода ця секта далі
працювати в Україні і брати зброю проти
українських бійців чи відповідальність
за падає міністра і його теж очевидно не
Лише його а всіх вас хто становить
більшість і Хто не виносить Це ці всі
питання в зал ми можемо говорити про
держкіно яке так несправедливо вивели з
підпорядкування Міністерства і в цьому
міністр був справий держкіно не працює
все що воно робить це поборює незалежний
центр Довженка фактично всі досягнення
які були в культурі від 14 по 19-й рік
не розвиваються майже все знищене
маленька частинка залишилася Може на це
по дякувати але я не знаю чи це дякувати
пану міністру чи громадянському
суспільству яка